i had a hard time last night with artem
i was like
and i was telling you i just felt so
down and depressed and i was like
gosh i just i feel like i'm working so
hard but i'm not seeing the progress i
want to see
and i haven't really bought any new
clothes because i just
am like no i'm going to get back in
these clothes nikki bella on her post
baby bod and speculation she's pregnant
with baby number two
i'm just i'm obsessed with being a mom
it's the greatest thing in the world now
the convo about baby number two
started on nicki's instagram when a fan
asked if she was expecting again
the wwe star responded by posting the
question to her story
and writing quote so a lot of people
have asked me this since the weekend
sucks lol but i talk about it on the
podcast tomorrow
hormones body changes and holding eight
pounds of water weight
today back to normal and nikki does
address it on thursday's the bellas
podcast
saying she's 15 pounds away from her
goal weight
you're only 5 pounds away see i was 10
and now i'm 15. oh wow
i told you i i've gained about 5 pounds
she
also gets candid about her insecurities
i also just can't help but look at my
skin like i just can see how
congested it is i feel like i have
layers to definitely like laser off and
i just it's hard to even look in the
mirror i'm like oh my gosh i have
circles and i'm wrinkles and i look
just older last month nikki admitted she
goes back and forth about plans to
expand her family on her podcast
so i thought it was one and done and
then mateo makes me want to give him a
sibling
and arno makes me want to give him a
baby girl
not that i have any control of that of
course nikki and her fiance artem
chigbensev are parents to a son
mateo who turns one later this year
i want to educate my baby just to have
such an
open heart and open mind and
live life through kindness and love and
shine the white light
and have no judgment
and stand up for the people and the
communities that need it
and so um i just i think
2020 for us who are having babies it's
gonna be a great year to actually
educate our kids on and look back and be
like this is
mommy learned a lot and this is what you
need to know too
the pair announced earlier this year
that they'll tie the knot over
thanksgiving weekend
you know i feel like artem he he
balances me in all the right ways and he
like i just get so busy and i'm such
i just get into hustler mode so much and
artem just literally and this is such a
weird
analogy but he he does make me stop and
smell the roses
[Music]